[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum hi guys what a great
start to the year yeah I'm very happy
you're listening I'm very happy you've
continued to listen I I sent all the
patreon boxes you know patrons who
patrons who support the podcast who I
always talk about who um without without
a doubt it responsible for keeping the
show on the air
um but uh you know it's I was just doing
all the boxes Send the boxes and stuff
and it's always say oh wow she's then I
write the notes and I'm like oh my God
you're still here thank you for the
support I can't believe you're some
people over three years now wow they
stick around they support the podcast I
I you know sometimes I go why why are
they why are they being so kind and
generous
but thank you guys uh I just want to
remind you uh to follow us on at insidee
podcast on Instagram and Facebook at uh
inside epod on the Twitter write a
review it really helps the podcast uh my
band sunspin uh our albums available
everywhere streaming we're streaming
everywhere so please please all I ask
you to do right now if you could take a
second and just go to Spotify and and
and click follow so we can get more
followers we don't have a lot of
followers and listen to the new album
it's available you can get tons of merch
on
um sunspin.com we've got mugs and
autographs and calendars and really cool
retro shirts and uh you could get zooms
from the band and uh also on the inside
of you online store we got a lot of new
stuff coming so check out the inside of
the online store we still have a small
script that um it's called Arctic it was
I think I thought it was gonna be the
last episode I ever did but the whole
cast signed it and that script's
available autographed it's only one of a
kind so I'm gonna I'll either you I'll
keep it up for a little while see if
anybody wants it okay anyway yeah what
do you do great guest today Emmanuel
shrieky
um
what I remember about this interview is
how in love with her I was I think
anybody listens to this we'll see she is
beautiful inside out she is talented so
kind so easy to talk to it felt
effortless and she opens up about a lot
of things and obviously she talks about
Entourage and she talks about her
um her career and her life and um this
was a really an enjoyable episode I
remember when she left I got I don't
want her to leave like yeah well guests
come and they go that's right that's how
it works that's life
um that is life it is life uh and again
if you want to join patreon go to
patreon.com inside of you and join what
everybody's been talking about
um anything else Ryan you have a good
New Year
yeah well I spent New Year with you yeah
yeah we played guitar and had some
Beverages and it snowed and we walked
around town and we ordered food and we
slept and you were in traffic a lot
going home and on the way but we made it
safely and it was nice to get away
wasn't it it was nice even if it's you
know not too far but you know it was
good yeah it was good it was good it's
good to get away and be around friends
and just forget about life for a while
yeah what song is that
and forget about life for a while it's
not Cheers piano man no without further
Ado folks please listen and enjoy the
wonderful Emmanuel shrieky it's my point
of view
you're listening to inside of you we
with Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know people that come on
the podcast
um
they think the room is a lot smaller
than it looks on TV oh yeah on the
screen than the computers yeah it's a
small room but it's quaint it's intimate
enough I love it you love it yeah
there's a lot to look at it's very
interesting I'm sitting across from Lex
Luthor
and I'm sitting across from the new Lois
Lana Lang it's a lot of legs
wow that's pretty cool huh that's very
cool you look fantastic oh you're so I
couldn't believe it because you know
your age is on you know on online like
of course mine is I'm 50. but when I saw
your age I go oh my god oh that's crazy
what you're 50. oh yeah I'm 50. don't
don't no no because you are for real
life yeah yeah you have great genetics
right do your parents like yum
um not not no uh I mean
it's hard to maybe it's hard to say I
mean my dad's 70 my mom's 75 I mean
they're starting to like you know
I mean I guess I have some good Genesis
well yeah I mean seriously like you like
you really like you could easily be 30.
thank you all right thank you 28. nah
come on don't know what do you think
over there no I agree
we all look young for our ages I'm so
surprised to you in person how like you
know because like you see the photos and
like oh of course every photo looks
great and then you see you in person but
you still you look very young oh I think
that's really lovely thanks it cracks me
up because you know on the show my
daughter in real life is 21 and and
Superman and Lois yeah right though
that's totally fusible it still trips me
up I'm like we'll be talking about
something and she's like oh my mom
always says the same thing and I'm like
you're playing a mom of two does it feel
weird did you think do you think when
you while you're acting you're like No
One's Gonna buy this did you feel that
in the beginning in the beginning 100 I
did in the beginning I was like
seriously guys this is the first time I
was playing because I played a mom of
like a baby but never of like a teenage
daughter I was like guys this is
ridiculous but then when you watch our
show
um
Dylan Walsh is the grandfather which is
also comical and how old is he I mean
mean he's what like his late 50s he
looks amazing well
it's okay hot grandfather what do you do
to to look good like what do you I mean
I know you I see your Instagrams and
your uh your uh exercising in your
Instagram you're doing Pilates for
someone who has deals with a lot of pain
and stuff I you know I
a lot of surgeries put ice hockey
growing up a lot of sports oh yeah does
Pilates is really something that can
help
does it help you what does it do what
does it do for you what does it do yo it
changed my life I mean I also have loads
of injuries
um I would say from what
do you know I don't know if it's a
combination of also just genetics like I
have Lucy Lucy tendons like I have a
torn labrum in my hip I've dislocated
both my shoulders total five times like
I feel really
um like I'm tough but I'm fragile do you
know what I mean like and I'm tough but
I'm fragile yeah I know but I'm chicken
[ __ ]
baby sorry sometimes I just have to do
that sorry that was perfect
um that was perfect it's been so
accurate um so anyways long story short
it changed my life like I had a lot of
injuries I was in chronic pain
um and it made me really really unhappy
and I've always been a very active
person but Pilates really changed my
life like I don't have I had a really
gnarly car accident and I was all jacked
in here and I'm not anymore so there is
really something to the whole you know
it helps elongate you and your spine and
your core strength and it has saved me
do you teach no you couldn't teach no
but do you have a teacher I do
she's the best of the best how much is
she an hour come on Celebrity talking no
she's is she like 150 an hour no well
I don't know what her rage I've been
working with her for so many years so
she doesn't charge me that but I think
that's her right right would you
recommend her to me
a million person where does she live
she's here she's so close she's on
Sunset really and it's her own Studio
let me tell you this she used to be an
Albany Lee dancer a what Alvin Ailey
what's an Alvin Ailey you don't know
that Alvin Ailey Dance Company in New
York no it's one of the Google it when
we leave Alvin Ali it's an unbelievable
Dance Company she was a professional
dancer for 20 plus years she's
incredible and her knowledge of the body
is other level and she's cool and so you
don't have as much pain anymore yeah I
have no pain anymore do you do your own
stunts on uh I used to I don't want
anymore it is
when I dislocated it which was a few
months ago on Superman and Lois you
dislocated your shoulder again Superman
and Lois what were you doing when you're
on wires no I was freezing cold
Vancouver I'm doing this Dope fight
sequence with Superman right and
um it was freezing I wasn't warm enough
I'd been training for weeks I blocked a
punch he kind of blocked it hard and it
just went like
you felt it immense pain it I have to go
to emergency that day on the set you had
to go to the emergency room yeah because
they wouldn't put it back in did they
try to put it back in no they because
you know if a nerve gets caught were you
crying I was bawling my uh wait oh this
is the best story ever I we told the
story I don't think so all right so I
could hear you it was it was out of
socket for um two hours because we're in
the middle of you shot in Vancouver
right oh yeah Smallville was in
Vancouver okay so we're in Delta a farm
in delta in yes sorry and uh the it take
we would take more time for the
ambulance to get there than for them to
drive me to the hospital so I'm going
across like bumpy Farm terrain
completely out of socket like can barely
breathe every step is like excruciating
I'm in my super suit and I get to the
hospital super suit yeah because it was
the alternate universe El Bizarro yeah
Lois Rowe Atlanta row Lana Rose yeah and
again go ahead go ahead so go ahead
you're in your shoes so we remember my
suit I don't even take you out of your
suit they couldn't like are you kidding
I couldn't move so I get to emergency
and I'm like CR I'm hysterical at this
point I'm begging them for drugs I'm the
doctor comes I'm like please just put it
back in socket and they give me some
morphine they gave me like a relaxant
they had to cut the costume the costumer
was with me they had to cut the costume
off and the nurse you know she sees it
I'm in this like full-on super suit and
I'm like so high at this point she's
like so who are you who were you
fighting dear
I was like I was looking around I was
like Superman
oh effed up on drugs Morphine at this
time it's just here you fight and you're
just you just look at him and say
Superman Superman she was like
okay
oh my God I read the whole thing was so
awful anyways that's the long-winded
answer so no I do not do my stunts
anymore that's it I'm done I have this a
most amazing stunt double let her do
what she does what how long before you
were fixed again did they did they put
it in socket back in the socket right oh
yeah while you were drugged up yeah and
you didn't feel it no it was instant
relief and then I was back at work the
next day are you serious I'm not did you
stay the night in the hotel in the
hospital no it was out like as soon as
they popped it back in did all the
paperwork I was out did Tyler who plays
Superman was he just like oh I'm so
sorry no he was like I mean he had
nothing to apologize for but he just
knew he when it happened he was like oh
and he just knew and and he was like
being very protective because you know
what's the what's is there anything
worse than getting hurt on set
um I think there is something worse
getting hurt during sex yeah I've done
that we're like
hang on hang on oh God oh God that's
what happens when you're 50. I'm not
kidding I've had I've had injuries where
I'm just like oh God oh God Mike I can't
I get my bad I just throw my back out oh
my God you yeah Brian have you ever been
injured during sex it's not like that
though
I'm living like hardcore slow down tiger
maybe take it easy I don't think I was
going that fast it was just like I don't
know what happened it was embarrassing
though that's hysterical yeah you got to
be someone that really likes you okay
maybe that wins maybe okay that would
win but you know I mean having like 300
people be like are you okay it's just
like oh God please I'm good I don't want
to make a big deal about this he just
want it back in but you were just like
you were in so much pain you were crying
on set you were like I don't care what
anybody thinks I am a mess oh I'm a mess
and you want it
well one of my Lex Luthor had just fell
off the shelf
do you want to hear something really
wild though and or um
uh our rad uh you know she's every other
um episode
I'd worked with him at the beginning of
my career on a film called wrong turn in
Toronto who's that with Wrong Turn yeah
um it was with um Jeremy Sisto and
Desmond Harrington oh nice Eliza and
um so on this movie
I dislocated my shoulder in a stunt
and Bob was the A.D I know Bob
what's his last name
No One Ever Knows the last name Bob he's
kind of like a middle-aged guy he's
probably my age he's the best but he's
really calm and mellow yes he was on
Smallville Bob oh I think so I think he
was yeah I love Bob he's terrible on on
on names in general I'm horrible yeah
probably the Bob's the best
yes
oh my God is this Bob Griffin that is
holy [ __ ] mom what up Bob Bob is the
best Thomas and I so I absolutely will
and so Bob
he's the ad on this episode and he comes
up to me he's like
not again and I was like and I look at
him I go oh you were there the first
time it happened with him the first time
years before like almost 20.
and now he sees you do it again again
and so he's like and I look at him and
I'm just like I'm out of sorts and I'm
like maybe it's because you're here yeah
you did maybe you made it wrong turn
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
did you have to audition for Superman
and Lois no you didn't
yeah you know I've talked to other
actors about this when you don't
audition it feels like oh look at me
like uh offer only but here's the
problem you never know if like they know
what they're getting they're like okay
this is what we want and you go on set
you start doing it right you're like oh
no no no we want something yeah that's
not what we wanted you know that that
could be a little scary when you're not
sure if you audition like oh that's what
they want good I got it I know what I'm
doing now absolutely no questions asked
no and absolutely were you nervous first
day
yes
terrified really oh my God but also too
you know I also the whole thing was so
strange to me like
um you know to your point is that I
didn't audition for this this came along
and you know I was thinking about this
in the car on the way up I thought if
this is going to come up or not and I
was like
I should start saying
I'll never
blah blah blah for the things that I
really want to do because I literally
was like I don't I've never I've I don't
think I've ever read a comic book I've
never watched I I don't watch superhero
things I don't like I know it's crazy
it's a little bit outrageous right and
so this came along and my you know my
team called me like I started laughing
like I was like gosh that's hilarious
okay like as if and they're like no no
no really like
they the you know the creator of the
show would love to have a meeting with
you and I was like kind of [ __ ] up
over it like I was like what
how
I don't even understand like I've never
ever worked on the CW before so what
would make them
have interest in there so a hundred
percent and like why me like I just not
nothing made sense I sat with Todd
helbing
best decision I ever made in my life
and uh yeah the rest is history but the
funny part was that the last time I said
it's not like I'd ever do blah blah blah
was when I said about
um working with Adam Sandler like I
literally was like it's not like I'd
ever do an Adam Sandler movie
and then I didn't know how to say that
so maybe I should start doing now you
auditioned for Sandler's movie right I
did no 100 how many times
twice with Adam the second time
never without him never with Adam was
Adam in the room
uh no he wasn't even in the room no I
met Adam are you his love interest yeah
it was a really weird situation because
originally Salma Hayek was cast and then
she got pregnant so she had to fall out
and I um
at the time randomly had a general with
Heather Perry
I know Heather you know Heather yeah
she's not there anymore is she I don't
know sure she ran Sandler's yeah
yeah so I had a you know I had a great
meeting with her and in the meeting she
was like
hmm
come with me and we're like in the golf
cart and she's like introduces me to
Adam Sandler he's playing basketball
that's exactly what you sound like you
look like Lopez
so good and then I met Dennis Dugan the
director yeah and then Dennis like oh
this is all happening and Dennis is like
yeah great uh I I yeah you're perfect I
would love for you to read and I and
then he's like so when can you audition
like the whole thing was so weird what'd
you say I was like
things are so hilarious I was like well
I'm doing a movie in Vancouver like I'm
actually flying to go finish a movie in
Vancouver so like when I rap maybe in
like 10 days I can come back and
audition and he was like okay
great
so I audition and I have to work on this
accent it's not like you know like I
wasn't gonna half-ass this what accent
was it Palestinian
[Laughter]
then I audition it went really well
apparently I guess the tapes were seen
but I know that there was a little
um behind the scenes like I'd heard
later on that
before they actually offered the part to
me Adam had sort of called around
to be like
tell me about shriki like we're thinking
about her for this
is this a good thing is this about
really so they want to know if you were
easy to work with easy to work with
would I be able to hold my own opposite
him like he wrote her line it's a big
deal right because Sandler is Sandler
and all his the all his co-stars have
always been you know
you know amazing what's he like on set
was it like uh Emmanuel do it do it
again but like say the line like this
and then turn your head like always
throwing [ __ ] at you he was well
definitely you know him and Dugan
directed even though Dennis Dugan was
the director Adam obviously was very
involved
um but he was just so fun he created
such a relaxed atmosphere
and
it
it just felt like super organic so even
if there was like something that we were
working out it just felt
it was like fun it never felt like there
was this enormous pressure
it was playful yeah he's a wonderful guy
he's a really wonderful human that guy
he's so kind to me oh I love that
I mean working with Sandler it had to be
like just like you're sitting there in
there say action you're like looking at
Adam Sandler this is like legendary
comedian legendary guy we all grew up
watching legendary and you're now you're
working with him it's got to be kind of
like Shell Shocked like oh my you had to
get that out of your system how do you
get it out of your system I don't think
you do I am an actor I'm acting now
learn your [ __ ] and forget about Adam
Sandler well I mean I think that
I don't know that you honestly do
because every day of that movie I just
remember being like
and then and then imagine
that I'm on the set
and there's a night where it's
Adam Sandler John Turturro Kevin Nealon
Rob Schneider and myself
doing a scene and I was like okay for
real what the [ __ ] is going on right now
did you say that like to anybody who
would listen like I was like this is so
surreal and like John Turturro oh he's
amazing I mean he's so amazing and again
like
one of the nicest humans I remember he
was he was he would get such a kick out
of it because I don't know if you know
this but he was very good friends with
Madonna Like That was yeah back in the
day in New York and somehow or other we
got talking and I was telling him of
like my obsession with Madonna when I
was a kid so literally we would be
sitting I'd be like okay so tell me some
more stories give me some more like yeah
some provocative stories just like fun
stuff not you know but it was really
cute and he got such like a kick out of
it like he loved how much I loved her I
know a great story where John Turturro
and John Goodman were working together
on a
Cohen Brothers movie yeah Big Lebowski
no it was a different one it was like
not Miller's Crossing or not it was
it was something with those two and they
were wrestling in the scene and
tituro or a Goodman didn't know his
lines or supposedly or something
and they were wrestling around and
finally come on Goodman [ __ ] learn your
lines he goes [ __ ] you tutorial more
people see me in one week on TV than
they see you in your career
I think they just were laying it on each
other but it was like oh yeah I just
remember somebody telling me that story
I wonder if it's true I'm sure there's
some truth to it but um did Sandler give
you his phone number and say yeah keep
in touch whatever after
no
did you want his number
I wish
that we could have been like friends do
you know but I don't think he needs more
friends
you know and I and I love his wife
Jackie so much and we had such an
exceptional time on this film like like
really exceptional yeah and uh but you
know like it's definitely one of those
like where if I ever saw him somewhere
I mean you worked with him for months
yes
I always feel like no one I will
remember me no matter what I know dude
we did a movie together well I feel like
I just like I don't know what it is but
I feel like I'm not gonna remember me
but but like so weird do you think that
that's because that's some like some
part of you just doesn't feel like
enough of course yeah I've always felt
like that you know there was a speech
that someone gave at a wedding recently
I won't say the wedding but the speech
floored me it was so emotional that
this person said
I love people I love I love my mother I
love this I love that
and logically I know that people love me
logically
like I know that
this person loves me but I've never felt
it I've never felt
that feeling that someone really loves
me I know it logically but I don't feel
it it broke me down it broke me down was
it that but was the thing that he'd
never felt it until now with this person
with this woman right it was beautiful
man it was beautiful there was a lot of
uh
yeah it was it was a lot of emotions at
this wedding and I just kind of sat
there with all these couples around me
yeah yeah I'm not finding someone I'll
find someone it will happen one day
we'll be at a wedding
she will get married hey um when you
were young when you were growing up when
you were you were born in Montreal but
you moved when you were two years old to
Toronto were you when first of all
did you have a pretty good childhood
mm-hmm you did were your parents always
there for you they were they always like
I'll love you do whatever you're
talented you're smart that they always
kind of yeah they were very very
supportive isn't that amazing when I
hear that I'm so amazed by it yeah I
mean listen there was a whole [ __ ] ton
of problems
but that was not one of them
we had uh
yeah it was what were the problems well
you know I my mom it was my was very sad
my mom was very sick am I growing up
so by the time I was 11 you know she was
diagnosed with
um colon cancer and then you know she
passed away like five years later and
you know so my whole sort of 11 to 16
was taken care of a Dying woman
um so it was a very like split identity
like like
sort of me at home and then you know me
at school and my dad and I together
would take care of her and my brother
and my sister were older and you know
they had tried to get married before she
passed away so they got they got married
like three months a month between the
wedding just the mom would be their mom
so Mom would see that so you know that
just had a lot of its own sort of stuff
and you know sadnesses and what have you
but my yes like my parents were so
supportive and very they loved the Arts
they love the art they I you know I grew
up in a french-speaking household but so
much I still speak French let me hear it
say I love this podcast it's amazing
fantastic
um so you know the radio was always on
like you know hajio Canada like always a
French radio you know as a family we
were always watching movies the you know
Mom would always garden and have like
you know classical music blaring and
she's like in her white caftan with all
the windows open she was like a
character out of a novel my mom wow
um so and you know when my dad when I
was little little he would like take me
to the to the symphony like so it was
always they just loved it so I think
they were classy it sounds like my
parents were really close yeah see my
parents were not classy really oh no
tell what do you mean like how like what
do you mean
I mean my parents were so classy but let
me just say like also I'm painting his
picture but it was like super humble
super middle class you know immigrants
that came with nothing and made
something Daddy spoke seven languages
because he was he just had a knack for
languages is he still with us no when
did he pass
Ed
um
nine years ago nine years ago yeah it
was a tough still to this day being
without him being without your mom oh
yeah do you still think about them
constantly oh a thousand percent
especially my dad my mom I was so so
young but my dad oh not a day goes by is
it easy for you to tap into emotions
when you're doing a scene if you need to
do you automatically go to that yeah
awesome yeah that will get you what's
the trigger what do you think of
which I miss him really
because I
desperately miss him
were you closest to him out of all your
siblings I think so yeah I hate to say
that you know if they ever heard this
they'd be like well [ __ ] you maybe we
did we did we had a bond it was an
undeniable bond that I think everybody
knew
um and also too you know we took care of
my mom together it was me and him we
were like this united front
and you know
yeah it was my dad and I yeah it's
amazing how things that happened to you
as a child
things that just you know
growing up
as an actor you can tap into that if you
do it's magical yeah it's hard sometimes
but I definitely have a few things that
I go to's that I could feel forget that
I felt for different roles and I just
tap into it yeah like where did that
come from I'm like well you don't want
to kind of say I know you don't want to
say and as as you know tragic or
triggering or whatever they end up being
gifts right yeah like it that saying
they're with you they're in the way
they're with you and also too that just
that thing of like what
a liquid doesn't kill you makes you
stronger like these think like if we all
have a story right we all have a story
we all have [ __ ] but
it becomes a gift when you can like tap
into it and use it for your art yeah
like it really does but wait sorry I cut
you off what do you mean when you say
you your parents were not that wow you
went back eight minutes
in Connecticut living in a duplex and
then got a kind of like a small house
and we moved to Indiana and we were
working our way into middle class and
then eventually my dad started doing
really well by the time I was out of
high school in college or out of college
but
um
you know I always it's so funny
there's got to be some psychology to
this but my mom if you went in the house
she had to take off your shoes
you have to see the vacuum lines and all
the carpets yeah she was like a monster
like that but if you opened up any
closet
the whole thing would collapse or you
opened up any drawer it was packed with
[ __ ] awful every drawer every cabinet
pills like this but on the outside it
was almost like looking at my parents on
the outside like oh these people are fun
they're they seem together they're oh
you know and then all of a sudden on the
inside you don't realize what's really
going on so there was chaos behind it
like hidden chaos hidden chaos I never
really talked about that but the closets
were just
atrocious
I mean you opened it up you could I mean
it was packed like a hoarder but like if
you didn't open anything or you didn't
open the drawer
wow that's so interesting I gotta talk
to my therapist about that what is that
that's so interesting I think my mom
always wanted everyone to think she was
normal that she was she had it all she
had you know she had class and she was
an intellect in this
and
you know it was one of those Wizard of
Oz yeah you look behind the curtain it's
like oh she was afraid of that I I think
we also I think so you know it's so
interesting you it's uh it's so
interesting I um
I had an oddly similar experience
so when my dad passed away
kanet was very
numb for
probably like about a year like I
actually couldn't shed a tear it was
wild did you go on any antidepressants
or anything I did well I mean not
antidepressants but I was taking too
many pills for sure and I was very very
anxious and you know just like all all
of the things just trying to just you
know constantly placate just like right
just this just tempering anything
because anything that I felt this felt
like too big and so it was like this is
like there's a year and then
maybe like five years after my dad
passed away this is so wild
um my cupboards
the way you're describing what your
house was that was like my house
and um
my best friend
um Emily she had encouraged me to do
Marie kondo the life-changing magic of
tidying up do you know that oh no oh my
God it's so amazing this is one of those
things where it says if you haven't
touched it get rid of it if you haven't
yeah does it spark Joy yes or no there's
no maybes
have you heard that no there was a
Netflix show right it was a Netflix show
yeah Sparks Joy but there's an actual
book and and they take you through
because she she anticipates like you
there's no you know people have such a
deep emotional attachment where it comes
to like pictures or cards right or like
whatever whatever or like instruction
manuals for whatever I know you don't
need them there's tutorials on YouTube
that's what she said she was like the
row them away you Google the model
number and boom there it is so there's
like an answer for everything so
initially
um brings this up to me and I have
such a visceral reaction which at first
was like uh no way could I do that and
then it became like this Obsession like
I have to do this and I realized that
you know when you open my cupboard it's
the same thing like like stuff was
crammed in there and I realized I hadn't
touched anything since before my father
died and I and I understood that I was
holding on to
what was and I like literally wasn't
ready to let go and it was this deep
Purge of an experience that kind like no
[ __ ] it changed my life
when I
actually did it it's organization it's
almost like
my doctor said my one of my therapists a
while ago I changed therapists I have
changed therapies because sometimes you
grow out of them you feel like I need a
different perspective but they said
something where you're you need to be
organized you need your office to be
everything to where you could find
things yeah
you have to have that or if it's in
chaos you will be in chaos yeah and it's
true I can pretty much find everything
for the most part I have a system but I
do hold on to things I don't hoard I
definitely get rid of [ __ ]
I mean look there's a lot of stuff here
but I also have two podcasts yeah but
this is like yeah and also too this is
your office like this is this isn't my
office this is the podcast oh I'm sorry
it's a creative room yes indeed do you
feel this is a weird question but it's
weird but when you're younger
I'm not talking as a child but when you
get older and you go oh my God if so and
so died I couldn't handle it I couldn't
[ __ ] no no no you don't understand I
couldn't handle it I couldn't handle it
I couldn't handle have you ever been
through that and then you realize when
you get older somehow you're able to
survive it somehow you're like when your
dad passed was it unexpected it wasn't
unexpected so were you anticipating and
thinking I can't get through this I
can't deal with this I can't do it this
is not gonna was it something
anticipatory uh yes I was definitely
um
I was moving through my absolute worst
fear
which is also oddly liberating
after the fact
um but I like I was like you know
watching my father die was
yeah
she just thought about it and you get
emotional well it's just if you knew him
you would be like
why should
somebody with that much
light and goodness like suffer the way
he did it wasn't like why did he die
because we all die it was like
why did he suffer like that and then on
my 40th birthday I did Ayahuasca and I
got the answer
you just went from emotional to
ayahuasca
I've been thinking about it but I'm
scared shitless of Ayahuasca yeah
because I feel like I I I just I'll
freak out but does it really work oh it
was so do you have a shaman
yeah I mean I did a one-on-one I didn't
do it in a group
this person sat with you and stayed with
you for like eight hours yeah it was
unbelievable it was unbelievable and
like it was unbelievable
that came up that whole thing came up
that ex specifically that thing came up
about just like why did he have to
suffer so much and everything and we you
know talked about it at length and then
she had said to me and like this is true
and I think about this a lot
I was shown or my father taught me
the like
the definition of grace
because like he
never
complained he
was so grateful for the life that he
lived
he was
um
to the end like still so
playful and
full of love and he was like
spiritual
and he was deep
and he just never once ever
complained or uttered why me
and I think it's really remarkable
because the
extreme pain that we was in was like
other level [ __ ] like he had a growth on
his sciatica
which if you deal with sciatica you know
this is like you know and he had
a pump of medication that was like
it's it's I guess it's like fentanyl
it's like 10 times more powerful than
morphine that he would press like every
few minutes
to help with the pain
and it was only after that I realized
like
holy [ __ ]
like
I don't even know what planet he was on
when he was sitting around with us
and we would you know get it like coax
him like a little child like Daddy how
are you feeling like
Daddy must have been high as [ __ ] trying
to get through the day
man you know yeah it's wild so anyway
you got through that with Ayahuasca in a
lot of ways it did
I did because like I just knew that to
be true
you know my dad was one of a kind
he really was yeah it sucks yeah it
really sucks I mean they had to go
through that and how old was he
he was a young 71.
still young 71's really young what was
his name Albert Albert
Albert tricky yeah
oh yeah cute
yeah
I mean that's amazing
this message is sponsored by discover
did you know you could reduce the number
of unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
so your brother
um
Patriot acting classes
growing up
yeah is that true yeah true how long was
it when he's paying for your acting
classes uh
16. how much are acting classes at the
time they're like a nine hundred dollars
it's a lot of money 100 for like 10
weeks or so yeah for like my first on
camera
you know TV commercial acting whatever
McDonald's
no that was later I worked at McDonald's
you did oh yeah I love it I was a
counter person and a fry guy I used to
have a mop I almost got fired for I did
get fired but I you had to mop in the M
like do an m with the with the mop no
you did not yes and the guy yes that's
how we were trained to do it
the ark the ark The Arches or whatever M
for McDonald's and then put it in
squeeze it dry put it back in water mm
do it back and forth I swear on my life
and I remember that's almost culty by
the way it was weird I remember the guy
was like Hey you're not doing the art
arches I'm like are you serious he's
like yeah that's how he trained you and
then I got I think I got um
I think I got fired because I was
stealing Big Macs or no no no no
um
fillet of fish no I love those filet of
fish
it was uh a mick uh
McFlurry no what was those things that
they have on occasion McRibs
I stole a whole bunch well it wasn't
stealing but they were left over but you
weren't allowed to take them after your
shift but we were closing and I took
like 10 in the bag and I brought it out
to my dad I go like this and the guy
goes we got my dad points and I turn
around it's the manager he's like what
are you doing I go oh well these were
gonna be thrown away he's like
and I went there and he I didn't get
fired right then but yeah anyway but um
that's amazing that your brother paid
for your acting classes so whenever you
win an award and you've won an award
before
you won some award I read did you get up
on stage and go I just want to thank my
brother who paid for my acting class oh
for sure I must have said something you
must have or like at least been like I
wouldn't you know like for my family
that just is like [ __ ] awesome you
know thanks for always supporting me
did you uh
did you always want to act from a young
age did you did you have those I'm gonna
ask a real question you have to answer
it real okay if this is the way you
thought did you think I just love acting
I want to act I don't care what I do as
long as it's acting yeah theatra yeah or
whatever the [ __ ] or was it like I want
to be famous actor I want to be I want
to do movies and I want to be famous and
make a lot of money and oh no the first
really yeah
yeah because don't forget I started in
the theater in like Community Theater in
like Unionville which is outside of
Toronto right so I'm like seven years
old and I'm like
I am
I've just discovered the greatest drug
of all time really which was like that
bond that you have when you meet like
when you've done a play with your family
I was like this is it
this is it this is what I want to do
this is it and so then when I auditioned
for high school there was a high school
being built that might where I lived
there was a fine arts program
I mean
I don't know what I would have done if I
didn't get accepted it would have been
like terrifying
but what would you have done if you
didn't become an actor I don't know
director not if you say actress anymore
is it just actor I say actress I know I
don't know anymore what to say and
whatnot you know it's funny I say that I
am an actor but when I'm talking
like if I have to still differentiate
like if I'm in a conversation with
somebody I'll be like oh that actress is
amazing something that actor then be
like well who are we
this helps differentiate you know when
what year did you get Entourage you
started in the second season of
Entourage right end of the second yeah
um what what did you what was your uh
what was it like being on set working
with all those guys it was a lot of
testosterone a lot of things a lot of
things going on there's not many girls I
mean there are girls but I guess there
were a lot of women on that show right
there were but my world was very with
the boys did you like being with the
boys I've always loved being with the
boys apparently I'm great with moving
with the boys I don't know why that is
but if you like look in my career I'm
oftentimes the only girl with
boys why is that I think because I had
an amazing relationship with my dad and
my brother and I felt very comfortable
around men they could say anything you
don't get offended no and also too you
know I always laugh I kind of joke about
this my boyfriend always laughs at this
I think that
I mean in some ways this is funny in
other ways this is really sad but I've
I've become super
I'm really good at flipping it
you really get what flipping it like I
can flip a situation like I can flip in
uncomfortable situation and not make
anybody uncomfortable it doesn't need to
be weird for you won't be weird for me
you don't allow yourself to feel
uncomfortable
I
yeah well it's not worth it
I mean unless someone really makes you
want somebody like you went over the
line have you had that
rarely rarely I mean I've had it yes
um on the work yep in the work place
um and I handled it
and there was very little backlash
and uh yeah I flipped it
I mean you ask any woman I'm sure
they're gonna say I've worked with a few
pigs in my life
right yeah
have you worked with some horrific
people before
no no most of them you can tolerate
and what was your experience on
Entourage did you did you really enjoy
doing the show the best what was so fun
about it 10 out of 10. 10 out of 10.
like an 11 out of 10. you remind me like
almost East Coast I mean you are really
yeah you do you're very East Coast yeah
you seem like you're from New York yeah
that people told you that of my whole
life yeah you just seemed like you're
from Long Island like oh yeah shrieky
she lived next to the pellegrinos over
on uh with an ocean side where I don't
have a [ __ ] what was it
where did my grandparents live I forgot
yeah but that's how next to the
pellegrinos so your name was chickie
Pellegrino she lived across the street
from my grandmother Ruth Ruth Eckstein
the pellegrinos lived across the street
Anthony uh yeah they all I walked over
you right yeah you right yeah so you
write screenplay but you need to use
that chicken Pellegrino yes I remember
walking over here you could play chicky
Pellegrino I remember walking over to
the Pellegrino's house to ask uh Anthony
if he had a screwdriver or something and
I looked down in the basement through
the window because they weren't
answering the front door and he was
going to town on this really on this
woman and it was so uncomfortable I saw
it and I go oh my God I think we locked
eyes and then I ran across the street
and I felt so uncomfortable wait I have
no chickens I know what you were about
to say at first I thought you were gonna
say and he was going to town like
working out no he was having sex
and you know it was just it was really
uncomfortable I have a lot of memories
you can't look at sparkling water the
same thing no no I can't oh my goodness
but Entourage was a great experience for
you great experience how many seasons
did you do uh
two through eight and the movie and the
movie yeah now for the movie did you get
paid a lot more than you would have in a
TV show
no did you ever feel like you got
compensated well for that show did I
ever feel like I got um
not necessarily no right
but at the time it
it seemed fine
so weird like I've just never in my
career until very recently been sort of
driven by money isn't that crazy you
know what I I don't think I was either
until I felt like some people were
taking advantage of right and when that
happens
you become business exactly [ __ ]
this is business exactly I'm delivering
you deliver exactly yeah and then you're
just yes and like oh yeah I've worked my
ass off for however many years and now
yeah it's time it's been time it's
bedtime you know and they will do
whatever they can to take advantage of
there's no there are there's no there
are no studios out there or networks
that want to pay you a premium price
that want to just make you feel good
like they you deserve this this Show's a
hit now we're gonna give you a raise you
shouldn't even have to ask if you're
working at a company all right and all
of a sudden you're working hard and
you're an integral part of this company
and the company stocks go up and the
company's worth a lot more if that boss
doesn't come in there and go you've got
a raise he's not a good boss and they
don't it's all about saving money it's
for the producers to save money so they
look good in the eyes of the studio it's
horseshit it's just how it works and
sometimes you got to stand up and go
faha could you I deserve more than that
and you have to fight for it and
sometimes
you piss a lot of people off and it's
okay yeah because it's business it's
business forget about it forget about me
yeah exactly
um
you said that the Bro culture of
Entourage still exists you think that's
of course it still exists right yeah
those guys every night outside of the
Bro culture yeah 100 of it still exists
yeah everywhere you look it's still
where you look oh all are you referring
to like how people always go on and on
about how misogynistic the show was
do they do that yes
constantly and you're you're upset by
that oh I think it's such horseshit
that's what the show was it was about a
bunch of these
but but but that was it the different
time a a different time B not that
different so what happened still now
like let's be real you know yeah it was
post me too before me too yeah but like
every week there's some new [ __ ]
that's you know has some is going going
down for something and so you know I
always just defended it I was like
I think I just always got sensitive
about it because I think people love to
hate on
things that are working
and so someone's always going to say
something and the truth is that you know
Doug Ellen was a genius and Doug Allen
simply wrote about
the [ __ ] that went on and he did it in
an entertaining fashion so it's like you
can [ __ ] on the show or just like hate
our business but he was writing about
our business like Doug used to say
oh my God this is tame
compared to what the real story is right
you know so yeah so I roll my eyeballs
because I just think it's ridiculous and
I think like you know people are
inherently fascinated with our business
and I think you gotta take the good with
the bad and that's a lot there's a lot
of bad it certainly is all right this is
called [ __ ] talking with Emmanuel
shrieky
did you get a lot of problems with your
name
say it again Emmanuel streaky
did people give you [ __ ] about your last
name were you like the shrieks oh
the um
shrinky Creek why
creaky [ __ ] nobody could ever nobody
ever it was tree quiet nobody could
understand why because you know I wish
but you know why though because when you
say it in French it makes if you speak
French the name makes sense you don't
speak French then you're like baffled by
the name because in French it's shriki
ch is like sh like champignon
so in French q-u-i is key key right so
it's shriki so in English doesn't make
quite as much sense but
[ __ ] talking with Emmanuel streaky um
these are my patrons top tier patrons
they get to ask questions if you want to
join patreon to support the podcast you
know I love you go to patreon.com inside
of you I'll send you a message and thank
you here we go Chris R these could be
fast answers oh okay right rapid fire
okay favorite memory for Entourage
uh filming at The Roosevelt Hotel at the
golden hour
why
literally outside
having a cigarette with Jaren Kevin
on Hollywood Boulevard in like dressed
to the nines shooting the show in
Hollywood and I was like
oh my God Roosevelt smoking a smoke
hanging out at the magic house just like
one of those moments where I was like
wait this is my life
that's amazing did you ever date anybody
on Entourage any of the actors Kev
Connolly and I are still nasties and I
gotta get him on the show we were
friends for a long time I haven't talked
in a while send me his email I gotta get
him on the show absolutely great and I
like the other guy too Jerry Ferrara
well I like Jerry how to do Jerry too
and then there's the other guy Jeremy
Pitta Adrian Grenier
Dylan Dylan oh of course Dylan well you
know they do the victory podcast yeah
maybe you can go on the victory podcast
Jamal F stoked that you're playing Lana
love Sloan and Entourage did you ever
feel that Hollywood tried to Typecast
you after Entourage or did you feel the
show gave you the chance to be more
selective with the roles you chose oh
great question nope they tried to
Typecast me and I said no for a whole
year before I said yes
nice Leanne what was it like to work
with Adam Sandler we already talked
about any fond memories you'd like to
share from your time on set
uh uh was there any time you couldn't
stop laughing oh my God all the time all
the time uh I would say
you know what you wanna hear a really
sweet quick sweet story I was wrapped
before the film was wrapped and they
were going to shoot in Mexico for some
segments that were supposed to take
place in Israel
so I was wrapped already and as my wrap
gift they were like come with us to
Mexico
so I first class everything first class
everything
um come hang with us give me a guest I
didn't I could have I didn't who cares I
was there with like my crew and my
castmates and had like the best time and
I was wrapped already and I that was a
testament to like the vibe of that film
wow yeah Sophie and we already answered
your question you said can you tell us
about your audition process for Superman
and Lois well she didn't did she did you
say Sophie Anne
Sophie M oh sorry M isn't your name my
name I thought Chelsea is your middle
name yeah Sophie Anne is your real name
Emmanuel Sophie and shrieking
Dana asks what advice would you give
your younger self
oh you know it's just so lame to say
this because I'm sure everybody says
this but it's so [ __ ] true it's like
worry so much
stress out so much I know it's all gonna
be okay
literally it's all gonna be mine would
be stop taking care do not feel like you
have to take care of everybody do not
feel like you have to give everybody
money do not feel like you have to try
so hard oh just enjoy life be present at
a young age
yeah oh you know what I'll I'll add as
well so the the don't worry one is very
real but you know what the other one is
steep
don't
don't dim your light for other people
wow
don't to make them feel better be your
light be your whole light
pretty amazing
Karina and hi bonjour
Emmanuel do you speak French and would
you be interested to act in a French
film I do speak French and I did do a
French film what what did you do that
was German that was I don't I can't do
French I can do German yeah
what is your last name Rosenbaum it
means uh red tree in German though wait
are you Jewish Hungary Romanian I'm Jew
okay okay
I mean I I wasn't sure
oh thank you thank you um so
thanks so
yes I did a French film it was a comedy
it was the best experience of my life
and it was called situation
and you spoke only French yeah
wow yeah it was great it's amazing I
want to do it again I have a French
agent so what now what are you doing now
besides well you're doing Superman and
Lois hey Superman and Lois are you
filming now yeah I go I fly back on
Sunday really yeah because you're busy
like you're like this is the only day I
have yeah yeah is it long hours for you
or are you gonna go in and out
uh in and out I think the Killer is the
the being the first one of the like six
a.m cold time Tyler he's there too from
the beginning to the end yeah is he
exhausted no
no how old is he he's 35. that's why
can't I couldn't do it he's brilliant
he's he's brilliant he's a nice guy he's
an amazing super he's got to do the
podcast I asked him he said he would
he's gotta I know oh I'll show him I'll
tell him you say you have to go on a
hundred percent yeah see she's got my
back Ryan what do you think of Ryan's
mustache I love it do you yeah I love
all you know does your boyfriend have a
mustache no but I love when he has
facial hair but I'll tell you I'm a
sucker for anything that's like 70s it's
like I love your glasses oh you do I
love that stash
uh I love 70s too do you like horror
movies love me too I love horror movies
did you see x no well it's it's it takes
place in the 70s and it's kind of like
these porn actors who end up at this
house and all the horror begins and it's
really good is it really iOS directed it
um okay X cool it's really good that
girl who's in it um uh she's on the new
Wednesday Adams show it's called
Wednesday it's coming out Tim Burton oh
yeah yeah yeah what's her name Wednesday
my friend Alan miles they created it
with Tim Burton
um it's called
her name's Jan Jenner
Ortega she's adorable isn't she and
she's great next oh my God great okay
favorite horror movie all the time the
shiny I knew it was gonna say Rosemary's
Baby it's because it's impossible
Children of the Corn
ER of the guy Malachi I though like
scariest yeah by the way just because
we're talking about horror
Dahmer is that what you're gonna say
that's what I told him my friend Tom
incredible it really is my friend I'm
only in episode five but my friend
texted me because we watched it last
night he goes not watching anymore I had
all kinds of crazy dreams about me and
you picking up Dahmer from jail that was
his text to me this morning
yeah it is dark but wow that guy is uh
the level I won't watch it that plays
Dominic it's disturbing he's just like
him if you watch the interviews with the
real Jeffrey Dahmer you're like oh Lord
and the scenes are so intense oh my God
it is the first episode is an episode
spoiler alert where
um it just shows you how he got caught
and then it starts the series which by
the way I loved that they did that
because I didn't actually know the
background of dollar at all
so I was like you're like this guy's not
gonna live what is happening
um
but I found it was so well done and that
lead guy Evan Peters Peters so my
favorite show of the past two years was
uh mayor of East Town I just thought it
was mayor of East Town yeah
mayor mayor what's your name Kate
Winslet I loved it he was in it he's the
young cop
who gets killed killed in the house yes
he was great
I flipped out when I figured that out
because I was like oh my God this guy's
honestly so sweet in that show such a
nice guy and here he's a monster I can't
I can't that just like wow amazing so
weird no it's weird this has been a real
tree what a treat
thank you thanks for having me for
allowing me to be inside of you today on
the show well that's that's what we say
that's the show's inside of you and
nobody laughs right I mean it's not
supposed to it's a serious thing here uh
this has been a real treat thank you so
much thanks
[Music]
again words can't describe what a great
guest I thought she was I hope you liked
her I hope you enjoyed it you got
something from it let me know write to
us follow us on our handles all that
stuff and uh really not much else to say
um I'll be at some conventions coming up
uh you can see me in Vegas on January
13th 14th and 15th at the creation where
Supernatural guys are gonna be we're
gonna it's gonna be a big party we're
gonna do a small nights welding and I
prizes Saturday night's a big music
night uh loud and swains playing and I
might get up and sing a song they want
me to sing a song Saturday night in
Vegas who's that loud and Swain who's
that their my friends they're a great
band they're they haven't they have a
new album recently it was a couple
months old but uh
Rob Benedict is going to be there he's
an amazing singer my friend Billy Moran
and um Mike and Steve will be there
and uh yeah all that stuff uh yeah you
know what to do uh thank you for
listening thank you for making this
podcast the one you listen to or at
least one of the ones you listen to
right now the top tier patrons these are
folks that give extra that really I I
can't believe they're still around that
are are keeping this podcast going if
you guys keep it going then I'll keep it
going that's as easy as that and if you
want to see me and Ryan continue this
and part of your Tuesdays or whenever
you listen to it um you know thanks for
the support uh patreon.com inside of you
and the new album don't forget that's a
new album
Amazon music Amazon music I think it's
everywhere YouTube music yeah it's it's
everywhere whatever yeah because please
follow us everywhere we need the
followers
um and listen to the new album it never
is what it is I think you're gonna
really like the album we worked really
hard on it uh here are the shout outs my
good friends Nancy d
hi Nancy I know we're trying to get
together for lunch uh or something it's
it's difficult but uh you know you know
I love you and we'll figure it out Leah
asks another one I mean I all these
people I just love Sarah V little Lisa
you Kiko hi Japan how are ya
um she's been listening for a long time
I love you Kiko you're great uh Jill e
hi chill Brian H hennen Camp Nico p is
still around and Robert B Jason Dream
Weaver Sophie my Sophie my Christian Keo
Raj
my wonderful wonderful friend Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike E held on Supremo 99 more Santiago
M where's my bus man where's my Lex
Luthor Buster making he's such a good
guy so talented Chad W Leanne P
heilingan Janine how are you Janine R
Maya P saw her in Pittsburgh uh Maddie
asked Belinda and Chris H Dave H it's
got to be Dave Hall
Sheila G Brad d r h Tabitha T Tom and
Talia and Betsy D of course Chad L Dan n
Angel M ran and C Corey K Dev Nixon
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Camille ask
Joey M A lot of these people I want to
meet that I haven't met Ryan and I want
to meet them at a con come see me damn
it and say hey it's me Chichi and Leah
they they visited they went to a con
Nikki G Corey Heather L Jake B Megan T
Mel s Orlando C Caroline R Christine s
Eric H Shane R Emma R Andrew M zeroichi
77 Andreas and Oracle Karina n Amanda R
gen B Kevin e Stephanie K Lena 82 jorel
Billy s jam and Jay Lee and Jay Luna R
Cindy e Mike app Stone Age Brian L
Cameron e to all the newcomers thank you
for the support I hope you enjoy patreon
it's a wonderful Community a lot of
people have made good friends they meet
up at cons they fun things so hopefully
treat them well to all the old patrons
treat the new patrons welcome them
friendships will start and hopefully
Blossom and thanks for the support for
the podcast from the Hollywood Hills in
Hollywood California I am Michael
Rosenbaum I'm Ryan Davis
all the way to the camera hey uh be good
to yourselves
it's 2023. let's do it right get healthy
um
feel better do more do more of what you
love and uh thanks for all the support
all right we'll see
[Music]